I must admit I didn't think much of
Graham Norton first time I laid eyes on
him look like a stiff breeze could blow
him over that was my first impression of
the man I could see why some people took
him for annoying he had a walk and a
talk that just wasn't normal around here
and boy did he drink
he drank like a man without a care or
worry in the world I hope to finish this
talk show one day I hope Michael stops
talking for just me I hope people stop
asking me to do stupid voiceovers like
it's just the greatest I mean there's
nothing better then than kissing a man
in a movie is if people say that's
difficult but they're wrong it depends
on the man like look at little and you
and me kiss now okay
[Music]
I hit them because hit them look he
needs to be he needs punishment like
this you big idiot
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah when our day in New York but this
woman didn't know who you were
yes and it was perfect because you know
basically I know what Lando and he gave
me some advice before Star Wars seven
came out and his advice was you know try
and secure right trying to secure the
love of your life before this stuff
happens and I did and I've done the
whole process you didn't know why I did
until we were driving through Times
Square she goes what do you do for a
living
looked up and I said that was me of a
favor I blocked out my phone I mean that
picture yourself just affected her kind
of starts in there was a guy with a huge
saber
yeah and then they don't know like you
know I'm 49 and like I deejay and stuff
like that so I was DJing it's just it's
Club these girls is about a DJ booth and
they were just so young on like how do
you that I'm 22 I'm 23 and oh my gosh
she's ancient she's 27 I'm like wow the
girl asked me how old I was when I told
him how old I was you would have thought
that I told him I had a terminal disease
with you I'm 49 oh my god
get you die from 40
let's pray he has 40 mine
don't take any advice for me the first
check I got I ran to the Mercedes dealer
I bought a car I didn't have money for
registration or insurance the police
told the vehicle because I was driving
without insurance you don't want any
advice for me to move get a jacuzzi I
just met all your brothers bring the
boys to Cali I got four kids I could
yell that tell me how much they hate me
they gave me a daddy I love you you're
the best dad ever Father's Day card
which is nice write that in that works
that's a beautiful thing but go have
some fun that's terrible advice but I
hear you and I got really drunk with two
friends in a hotel room when the kids
were all in bed like really drunk we got
a bottle of tequila between the three of
us and then I heard kids running around
it's so bad there's kids running around
I'm quite good at pretending to be sober
when I'm not so I said I'll I'll go out
and I'll deal with this to my to my
friend Tony
and I went out and there were these kids
all in their nighties and pajamas all
giggling and I went out what's going on
here sorry I said you don't you should
be in your beds is absolutely
disgraceful and I was doing a beautiful
job when Tony came out of my room I
don't know why he was just in his boxers
you and Liam got chlamydia from a koala
bear might confirm that's not true you
were thinking of becoming in a state
agent okay set your face for this one I
really want to see this one okay you had
a sexual relationship with Barack Obama
wavering up there before evilly not
allowed to say don't see a picture of
him Valerio okay so a mere tonight to
surprise my beautiful wife Alma Alma yes
see she actually indulgence tonight Oh
where's Alma are you sure she's gone no
your beautiful wife Alma's still here
off you go Valerie it was a nice
surprise yes of course okay
she's pregnant Oh our first baby Oh
we don't know yet the gender of the baby
because I really want wait until the
baby's born
of course but she really want to know as
soon as possible
oh yes so the doctor wrote this piece of
paper
oh the gender of the baby and I say to
her we will open in a special occasion
so because she loves you and your show I
believe that tonight is the best may I
open yes
[Applause]
Anthony Joshua
I'm still going okay I tell you what was
yours eight eight B was three thousand
six seven she wasn't what six seven two
six three two so if you don't beat back
so tightly okay okay here we go this
technique adjud the world
you do some rope might rip something
every time flick swan dive okay no no
that's dangerous
I don't even Devon years
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]